the new trailer for Godzilla has been
released and I have gotten a lot of
requests to talk about it for a good
reason
this trailer looks freakin awesome I've
been a Godzilla fan my whole life I grew
up watching the older ones on VHS tape I
watched Godzilla vs. King Kong Godzilla
vs. Megas this and that and all that
kind of stuff I watched them all when I
was a kid I even like the American
version when I was a kid now I don't
like it now it's really dumb and stupid
it's cheesy and Matthew Broderick is in
it and Matthew Broderick was in the the
Godzilla movie and there's a character
that's obviously making fun of Roger
Ebert his name is mayor Ebert and his
partner's name is gene or whatever it's
it's it's really crazy what they did
with that movie nevertheless this movie
looks incredible it really does I feel
like they are doing what Godzilla needs
to have and what that is is a realistic
sense of fear a actual knowledge of you
know what this is bad what is happening
this isn't just a big dinosaur wandering
around we're all going to die and this
trailer seems to capture that and I'm
really hoping that the movie does
because it really feels as if there is
that urgency that is needed in a
Godzilla movie where you have characters
and they're like crap we are gonna die
this thing is actually here we're not
gonna pop jokes every two seconds we're
actually afraid for our lives and this
movie trailer actually really captured a
bit of a frightening vibe like I was
like crap I'm actually scared of
Godzilla which is nuts because as a kid
you like Godzilla is so cool gay special
effect dinosaur person but in this movie
trailer I'm like Godzilla's kind of
freaking me out you really captured like
this very realistic sense of giant
realism like I that's just the best way
I can describe it as I watch the trailer
I really was like wow that looks like a
giant thing I'm kind of getting goose
bumps when I saw I gotta be honest with
you it kind of freaked me out the way
they filmed the movie and I think that
that's gonna really be awesome in the
movie because there's an aspect of this
movie that I'm like this might actually
scare me Bryan Cranston looks to be the
voice of reason in this trailer where
he's like that one guy who's like look
this is bad this is really bad do it
do it shoot me Jesse shoot me cuz
Godzilla's coming and you need to shoot
me the movie looks great the special
effects are mind-blowing Lee
realistic-looking you get a couple cool
shots of Godzilla in there it looks like
Ken Watanabe in some way was involved
with the creation of the creature they
seem to talk about that in the trailer a
little bit you get little hints of
things but I love the way they're doing
this promotion because I'm like amazing
spider-man 2 where we've seen like
probably 90% of the movie already in the
trailers this movie is hiding things
that's making Godzilla like this thing
you want to come see they're having like
very brief little glimpses of him it's
perfect the way they're doing it I'm
very very excited for this movie I think
it looks spectacular I am pumped to see
it what do you guys think of that
Godzilla trailer are you as excited as I
am because this movie is looking like it
could be one of the best movies of the
year let me know below what you thought
of it and as always guys thanks so much
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes